WELCOME BACK TO THE REST OF THEG
DEAL AS VANCOUVER MOVED SOME HR.
AND THEY DID NOT HAVE EASYBALLYD
ELIAS PETTERSSON A NEW CONTRACT,
HAVING MISSED HAL NOW FOR MILLE.
TO THE POINTNT IS GREISS WHO SL.
[ Whistle
DeKEYSER NOW FOR DETROIT.
HE HAD THAT SHOT MANAGER
KEN HOLLAND HERE USED TO CALL
THAT THE LITTLE BUS LEAGUE THATS
GAME AND THE REDED YOUR
EVENING.
KEN: I CAN GO ON FOR THE REST OF
MY LIFE. HORVAT AND NOW FOR
MILLER, BACK NOW TO HUGHES.
AND WE WERE JUST SPEAKING OFPRI.
MICKEY: AND THEHE
KEN: HE PLAYED A TON AGAINST
GOOD TEAMS LIKE FLORIDA, TAMPA
AND HE WITHT RIGHT THERE,
THE PLAY.
HE WAS HAD TO SET IT TO CENTER.
RAYMOND WITH IT.
ERNE NOW
COMING IN.
MICKEY: I MEAN, WITH 13 NEW GUYS
IN THE LINEUP, YOU WOULD THINK
[ APPLAUSE ]
[ CHEERING AND APPLAUSE ]
KEN: WELL, YOU CANNOT MAKE THAT
MICKEY: ATTABOY.
THERE FROM LUCAS RAYMOND ANDY
THEN ALL OF IT UNFOLDING FROM HS
ZADINA, GETTING.
MICKEY: WHAT A MOVE BYDER AND YW
THAT HE WILL RELOOK AT THAT
EARLY ON IN THE SEASON HERE.
AND
HORVAT, STOPPED IN BACK OF THE
NET.
NOW A GIVE MAN TO UNABLE TO CHA.
KEN: OH, BOY
MINUTES. NETMINDER
GREISS.
MICKEY: IT MIGHT HAVE HIT THENY.
KEN: AND RASMUSSEN, HORVAT, ON
THE DRAW, VMICKEY: IF YOU ARE A,
MIDDLE OF ALL
OF T
AND HE GOES BACK TO CONGRATULATE